CHAMP THERE AND THIS
IS IT, BRANDON
YOU CAN SEE THERE AT THE TOP OFO
MINUTES, TRIP
GOOD, CRISP PASSING, GETTING
GRUBAUER MOVING THERER
LAST YEAR.
NOLAN PATRICK.
ZADOROV.V.E, WITH
NUMBERS AND A MY!
A.J.: AND CHANCES HERE AT BOTH
ENDS OF THE ICE AND BRANDON
TANEV, TALKING ABO THE POWER, RV
PACIORETTY, VEGAS IN FRONT!
MARTRT
TRYING TO GET THE POWER PLAY
GOING.
PATRICK TO STONE, EXCELLENT KNIS
HERE.
DOING A FINE JOB THROUGH THETEP.
THAT SHOT, WIDE.
SET UP NOW, SHOT, KICK SAVE,
STEPHENSON,
THERE LOOKING FOR EXPIRING, A
CHANCE FOR MARCHESSAULT, THE
WORK NOW BEHIND THE PASS,
SCORE!
NICOLANE.
LOOKING FOR A BETTER PLAY.
BANKS IT.
GETTING GRUBAUER
YOU DO NOT EXECUTE THAT
PRESSURE.
JOHN: KI
DUNN, WALKING IN, A LOOOO
PRICE IN FRONT THAT TIME.
WINNING THAT BATTLE AGAINST
ALEC MARTINEZ.SCHWARTZ, I BELIEA
PUCK INSIDE.
LOOK TO THE TOUCH,
SMITH AND THEN HE TIME WITH
WHITECLOUD.
IN FRONT.
WENNBERG WITH IT, LOOKING TOIT V
AGAIN, BLOCKED, BUT IT
IS BLOCKED.
MARTINEZ, A NICE P
HOLY SCHNEIKEY! THE HEAD RIGHT
THERE, ON
JOHN: AND STEPHENSON, IT IS IN
THE BACK OF THE NET!
A GOOD G IT A
PENALTY COMING
UP, TWO ARMS IN THE AIR AND
WE'LL SEE, IT ISINE.
THAT TIME BY PIETRANGELO.
WIDE, CALL
HERE IN